[Musique]
la cage va ouvrir son premier restaurant
en France à Bordeaux le 1er juin c'est
grâce à un partenariat avec l'entreprise
française boulangerie ange que ce projet
est rendu possible Jean Bédard et le
président chef de la direction de groupe
grandios bonsoir Monsieur veédard
bonsoir pourquoi
mais en fait ça fait de longtemps qu'on
nous dit vous devriez sortir du Québec
je pense qu'on est partout à travers le
Québec avec une quarantaine
d'établissements et soit disait pourquoi
vous allez poser tous unis Floride
l'Ontario et on avait souvent des
demandes de la France et bon on ne se
partenaire là est arrivé avec quelque
chose de sérieux surtout avec le
changement qu'on avait fait au niveau de
la cage au niveau du menu tout ça je
pense que c'est un des aliments des
planètes comme on dit le bon partenaire
dans le bon temps qui partage un peu les
mains valeurs qui connaît le Québec
parce que déjà implanté donc voilà c'est
si j'avais dit moi je disais toujours
son sort un jour on va sortir vers la
France et francophone on est des cousins
donc avec un pays qui a ses traditions
qui a notamment ses traditions
culinaires ces traditions sportives
comment vous vous insérez dans ça mais
je pense que c'est en développement la
France en transformation on regarde tout
à peu près toutes les concepts
nord-américains ont beaucoup de succès
en ce moment en France les jeunes
semblent vouloir adapter ce qui est un
peu plus international au niveau du
support également les supports qui
traditionnaient le rugby le soccer
évidemment fonctionne bien mais ils sont
de plus en plus ouverts au basket au
football américain de football en France
exactement
on s'habitue mais je pense que il y a
vraiment et le fait qu'on vient du
Québec je pense que c'est un attribut
encore plus positif je pense que nos
cousins français adorent ce qui vient du
Québec donc on pense qu'on a un bon
partenariat et un bon timing pour eux
pour y aller est-ce que c'est une
opération risquée pour vous pas pour
nous évidemment oui c'est toujours on va
mettre beaucoup d'efforts de temps
d'argent c'est le capital va être plus
investi par notre partenaire français en
France lui achète les droits d'utiliser
notre marque nous c'est évidemment on va
mettre du temps des efforts et on va
engager également des dépenses mais on
pense que beaucoup de potentiels je
pense que notre partenaire et nous dans
cette opération là on peut on peut y
être gagnant ce concept de brasserie
sportive qu'on connaît bien à blocage
est-ce qu'il existe en France il y a des
bistrots en France il y a des écrans les
gens écoutent aussi du sport ensemble
comme ça dans des mais pas dans des
grandes proportions comme ça avec des
grands écrans il y a beaucoup de des
craintes téléviseurs des petits pubs
tout ça mais des grandes surfaces comme
chez nous non je dirais que des 6000
pieds carrés et on peut des surfaces
comme ça et thématiques sport il y a une
volonté pour ça il y a une demande pour
ça mes partenaires français
absolument ça fait longtemps qu'on a
toutes les années on a des demandes à
Grenoble à Strasbourg tout ça on a
beaucoup d'employés qui travaillent chez
nous au Québec sont des Français qui me
disent toujours ça fonctionnerait
tellement bien en France ce genre de
concept-là je pense que des fois on
arrive avec quelque chose de nouveau
faut regarder ça justement c'est pas
parce que il y a pas de il y en a pas
que ça va marchera pas c'est souvent
parce que ça a jamais été offert assez
consommateurs là mais je pense qu'on a
une formule qui va plaire aux Français
si ça marche à Bordeaux est-ce que ça
est-ce que c'est Grenoble ensuite et
est-ce que c'est Paris ensuite mais en
fait je dirais que la on a le site les
sites qu'on a regardé Aix-en-Provence on
a regardé ce côté de Lille au nord
également Nantes tout ça c'est grand
c'est grand endroit là évidemment on va
s'assurer que le concept à Bordeaux
fonctionne bien avant de se lancer dans
une expansion mais tu sais il y a trop
U8 millions de personnes au Québec à 63
millions de Français je pense quand même
un marché intéressant pour nous là mais
c'est plus qu'un marché intéressant
c'est un grand marché qui pourrait
transformer votre entreprise oui moi je
pense que je pense que ce geste là qu'on
pose a beaucoup de potentiel si on le
fait comme faut je pense qu'on a un
concept qui n'existe pas tant que ça
même à travers le monde il y a beaucoup
de sport basé juste sur la bière et je
pense qu'on a quelque chose qui pourrait
peut-être nous emmener ailleurs on va
commencer évidemment par la par la
France mais je pense que ça pourrait
transformer notre organisation d'autres
pays que la France que vous faites eux
on a une entente pour la France et la
Belgique les pays francophones mais
après ça on verra je pense que c'est
plus facile comme ça au niveau de la
langue il n'y a pas de barrière au
niveau des manuels d'opérations ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile et de la
communication il y a d'autres types de
barrières est-ce que vous devez adapter
vos menus pas tant que ça leur franchisé
veut le menu de la cage évidemment au
niveau de l'approvisionnement il y a des
choses qui sont un peu différentes mais
pas tant que ça je pourrais vous dire
des choses qu'on a dû ajouter au menu
donc les planches de charcuterie qu'on
va ramener nous-mêmes au Québec parce
que c'est une bonne idée la carte de
dessert va être beaucoup plus élaborée
les gens mangent beaucoup de desserts en
France contrairement à nous ici donc
certains ajustements qu'à peu près 85-90
% de notre menu va se retrouver à
Bordeaux etes-vous la cage remis
complètement de la pandémie
oui je dirais à 85 90 % là il y a encore
certains secteurs c'est un petit peu
plus difficile de retrouver la main
d'oeuvre le rythme qu'on avait mais je
pense que honnêtement on s'en est bien
remis assez rapidement les consommateurs
sont rendez-vous heureusement et je
pense qu'on est en bonne position on a
fermé pendant trois ans cette année on
va n’ouvrir quelques-uns donc je pense
qu'on prend une bonne Hélène notre
division au détail va bien parce que la
pandémie a fait en sorte que ça a créé
de la demande donc oui je suis direct on
est en bonne position mais il faut
jamais prendre une pour acquis dans
restauration je tiens à remarqué que
vous étiez très présent dans les médias
pendant les fermetures de magasins
durant la pandémie vous avez pris le
bâton de pèlerin pour défendre votre
industrie alors c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir aussi pour des ouvertures de
restaurant merci merci Monsieur Madame
merci beaucoup merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI